.
Woher kommst du?
Wenn man diese Frage einen Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund fragt,
um eben diesen Migrationshintergrund
herauszufinden,
ist das noch harmloser Small Talk
oder schon geschmacklos?
Wo verläuft die Grenze
zwischen Neugier und Rassismus?
Das wird derzeit
diskutiert unter #vonhier.
Viele sind wütend oder genervt:
"Hört auf mich zu fragen,
wo ich herkomme!"
Auf beiden Seiten: "Das wird man
ja wohl noch fragen dürfen!"
Manche sind einfach nur verwirrt:
"Warum sind alle wütend?"
Ich bin ja für Aufklärung
statt Aufregung.
Egal, wie hitzig
diese Debatte sein mag,
Ich glaube,
dass es ein paar Punkte gibt,
auf die wir uns tatsächlich
alle einigen können.
Mal schauen, ob das klappt.
*Titelmusik*
Also, auf was können wir
uns denn alle einigen?
Ich hab in dieser Debatte
vier Punkte ausfindig gemacht,
also der niedrigste Konsens,
den man unaufgeregt haben kann.
Doch bevor wir zu diesen Punkten
kommen, eine kurze Einführung:
Losgetreten wurde die ganze Debatte
durch Dieter Bohlen und diese Szene:
Hallo, ich heiße Melissa.
Hallo, Melissa.
- Hi Melissa.
Woher kommt die Melissa?
- Herne.
Und Mama und Papa, wo kommt ihr her?
Philippinen oder...
Nein, auch aus Herne.
Kommt ihr irgendwie...
Wo kommt ihr her? Gebürtig?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oma und Opa oder so?
Bist du die Mama?
- Ja.
Wo kommt ihr her?
- Ich komme aus Thailand.
Ah, Thailand.
Okay, da bin ich auch bald.
Eigentlich erst durch Malcolm Ohanwe
und diesen Tweet.
Dann durch Ferda Ataman
auf Spiegel online.
Dann haben sich ganz viele
auf Twitter beteiligt.
Die Diskussion
ist immer noch im Gange.
Die Bohlen-Geschichte
kennen wir ja alle.
Mit "wir" meine ich Menschen mit
sichtbarem Migrationshintergrund.
Woher kommst du?
- Aus Nord-Baden-Württemberg.
Ich meine,
woher kommst du ursprünglich?
Ursprünglich aus Südhessen.
Wenn du in Deutschland lebst und
dein Gesicht nicht kaukasisch ist,
ist die Frage "woher kommst du?"
wahrscheinlich die häufigste Frage,
die du so im Alltag von
fremden Menschen gestellt bekommst.
Die Geschichte ist nicht neu,
nur wurde sie selten
so öffentlich diskutiert wie jetzt.
Warum mögen viele mit Migrations-
hintergrund diese Frage nicht?
Na ja, mit jedem "woher kommst du?"
wird man daran erinnert, dass man
nicht so aussieht wie von hier.
Das ist ungefähr so,
als wärst du im Fußballstadion
und alle um dich herum haben das
Mannschaftstrikot an, nur du nicht.
Dabei bist du im Herzen genauso
ein Fan von dieser Mannschaft,
doch alles, was die anderen sehen,
ist, dass du kein Trikot anhast.
Viele Deutsche
mit Migrationshintergrund
fühlen sich genauso deutsch wie
Deutsche ohne Migrationshintergrund
und möchten auch gerne
so deutsch gesehen werden.
Wir wollen nur deutsch sein.
Ist das so schwer zu verstehen?
Doch das Fremdsein
ist uns ins Gesicht geschrieben.
Da weiße deutsche Menschen
dieses Gefühl jetzt nicht kennen,
wird es auch leicht missverstanden.
Vor allem, weil in dieser Debatte
leicht der Eindruck entsteht,
dass diese Frage "woher kommst du?"
wie ein Schlag ins Gesicht ist.
Nein, so dramatisch ist diese
eine Frage jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Es ist wie der stete Tropfen,
der den Stein aushöhlt.
Es ist die Häufigkeit, mit der man
mit dieser Frage konfrontiert wird,
also der Alltag ist voll mit
kleinen, feinen Erinnerungen daran,
dass man irgendwie
nicht so richtig Teil der Crew ist,
dass man irgendwie anders ist.
Deswegen fragen Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund:
"Könnt ihr nicht einfach
mal unsere Gesichter akzeptieren
und das nicht zum Thema machen?"
Jetzt gibt es auf der
anderen Seite aber auch Menschen,
die ein aufrichtiges Interesse haben
an der Herkunft des Gegenübers.
Vielleicht sehe ich dich ja
absolut als Deutsche,
möchte aber trotzdem wissen,
wo deine Wurzeln sind.
Nicht zuletzt sind die
ethnischen und kulturellen Wurzeln
auch ein wichtiger Teil
einer Persönlichkeit
und ein Interesse daran
kann auch schön sein.
Sagt man: Seid nicht so unsensibel
und hört auf diese Frage zu stellen.
Oder sagt man:
Stellt euch nicht so an und
beantwortet eine harmlose Frage.
Damit kommen wir zum 1. Knackpunkt
oder zum 1. Punkt,
auf den wir uns alle
einigen sollten:
Vor allem, weil wir über typische
Small Talk Situationen sprechen,
wo sich zwei Menschen begegnen,
die sich erst getroffen haben.
Nehmen wir mich als Beispiel:
Ich heiße Mai.
Meine Eltern sind Vietnamesen.
Und niemand weiß, wie man
meinen vollen Namen ausspricht.
Nguyen wird so ähnlich ausgesprochen
wie das Nürn von Nürnberg.
Statt Mai Thi Nürnberg sagt man
einfach Mai Thi Nguyen Kim.
Ich bin in Heppenheim
aka. Vettelheim geboren
und in Hemsbach
an der Bergstraße aufgewachsen.
Unschwer zu erkennen, an der Art und
Weise, wie ich Gehirn ausspreche.
Gehirn.
Gehirn. Heißt es nicht so?
Ich bin Deutsche,
ich fühle mich auch so.
Aber wenn mich jemand fragt,
wo ich herkomme,
dann antworte ich meistens
ganz gerne und sage,
dass meine Eltern
aus Vietnam kommen.
Ja, die Frage wird oft
etwas unbeholfen formuliert,
Aber solange ich das Gefühl habe,
dass die Motivation der Frage
einfach Neugier ist,
bin ich persönlich cool damit.
Die Journalistin Vanessa Vu z.B.
hat zwar auch vietnamesische Eltern,
hat aber ganz
andere Erfahrungen gemacht.
Hier schreibt sie sehr eindrücklich,
warum die Frage nach ihrer Herkunft
mit ziemlich viel
persönlichem Schmerz verknüpft ist,
dass sie deswegen schlicht
und einfach keine Lust hat,
darüber zu reden,
vor allem nicht mit Menschen,
die sie gerade erst getroffen hat.
Und meine Eltern z.B. antworten
immer sehr gerne und fröhlich
und unbefangen auf die Frage
nach ihrer Herkunft.
Und das auch in vielen Fällen,
in denen ich
nicht so cool reagieren würde.
Bei meinen Eltern bekommt die Frage
manchmal
einen unschönen Beigeschmack.
Regelmäßig werden sie gefragt:
Und warum leben Sie in Deutschland?
Und wann gehen Sie wieder zurück?
Manchmal werden sie sogar
nach ihrem Beruf gefragt,
gefolgt von: Warum arbeiten Sie
nicht in Vietnam? Bitch!
Das ist dann
kein aufrichtiges Interesse mehr,
sondern eine deutliche Ausgrenzung,
ein klares: Sie gehören nicht hin.
Versteht ihr? Das waren
drei einzelne Erfahrungsberichte.
In diesem Fall
von Vietnamesen in Deutschland.
Aber es gibt ja noch mehr Menschen
mit vielen Hintergründen
und Geschichten und Erfahrungen.
Ich kann unmöglich meine Erfahrungen
auf andere übertragen.
Deswegen kann ich auch nicht
als Fragender verlangen,
dass sich der andere
nicht so anstellen solle
oder nicht so empfindlich sein soll,
weil ich kann einem anderen
einfach nicht
seine persönlichen Erfahrungen
und Gefühle absprechen.
Kommen wir jetzt
zur anderen Seite des Dialogs.
Hier gibt es auch einen Punkt, auf
den wir uns alle einigen sollten:
Aus Unwissenheit,
können wir andere verletzen.
Z.B. Beispiel, weil wir nicht
wissen, wie sich andere fühlen.
Trotzdem ist es wichtig,
ob ich die Absicht habe,
jemanden zu verletzen oder nicht.
Und trotzdem höre ich
in dieser Debatte immer wieder:
Es ist egal, ob das jemand
eigentlich nett meint.
Das ist ein gefährlicher Satz.
Es ist völlig legitim zu sagen,
du hast es nicht böse gemeint,
aber mich hat es trotzdem verletzt.
Oder: Du hast es nicht böse gemeint,
aber ich mag diese Frage nicht
und werde sie nicht beantworten.
Völlig legitim.
Aber wenn man sagt:
Du hast es nicht böse gemeint,
aber darauf kommt es hier nicht an.
Dann ist man
einen Schritt zu weit gegangen,
denn natürlich kommt es darauf an.
Natürlich ist es wichtig, ob
jemand aufrichtiges Interesse hat,
nervige Vorurteile
oder Fremdenhass hegt.
Das ist doch nicht egal!
Es macht doch einen Unterschied,
ob jemand wissen möchte,
ob ich aus Vietnam bin,
weil er mir mit leuchtenden Augen
von seinem Vietnam-Urlaub
erzählen möchte.
Oder ob er mir danach sagt,
dass ich dahin zurückgehen soll.
Wenn wir Fremdenhass in einen Topf
werfen mit Unbeholfenheit,
dann ist das nicht nur sehr unfair
für die unbeholfenen Menschen,
sondern es mindert auch die grausame
Bedeutung von Hass und Rassismus.
Gut, so viel zur Theorie.
Aber wie verhalten wir uns
jetzt in der Praxis?
Hier kommen wir zur nächsten Sache,
auf die wir uns einigen sollten:
Mit Ping-Pong-Spiel meine ich
diese klassische Bohlen-Situation:
Woher kommst du ursprünglich?
- Aus Deutschland.
Woher kommst du eigentlich?
- Aus Hemsbach.
Ich meine...
- Hemsbach an der Bergstraße!
Die ganze Konversation
ist halt nicht Lösungs-orientiert.
Erst mal, an die Fragenden:
Wenn ihr eigentlich wissen wollt:
Woher kommen deine Gene?
Ihr aber eine Antwort bekommt wie:
Hemsbach an der Bergstraße!
Dann gibt es dafür eigentlich
nur zwei plausible Gründe:
A, euer Gegenüber hat euch
sehr wohl verstanden,
ist aber schon
mal mindestens genervt
und hat einfach keinen Bock,
diese Frage zu beantworten.
Oder B: Gegenüber
ist ein 5-jähriges Mädchen,
das in Deutschland aufgewachsen ist
und nicht weiß, wovon ihr redet.
Und deshalb ist Nachfragen
einfach nicht zielführend.
Mit jedem Nachfragen
werdet ihr nur mehr Missmut
oder Verwirrung stiften.
Doch auch die Gefragten
tragen nicht zur Lösung bei.
Wir wissen doch ganz genau,
was diese armen Menschen
versuchen herauszufinden.
Solche Spielchen
stiften ja nur Verwirrung,
vor allem, wenn der andere gar nicht
weiß, warum er euch gerade nervt.
Dann wird er in Zukunft
den Nächsten fragen, wo er herkommt,
weil er immer noch nicht weiß,
was er falsch gemacht hat.
Was wäre stattdessen zielführend?
Einfach mal an die Fragenden:
Geht doch einfach
auf die Antwort ein.
Woher kommst du?
- Aus Hemsbach.
Kenne ich nicht. Wo ist das?
Wenn ihr euch für die Herkunft
eines Menschen interessiert,
dann sollte der Ort,
an dem er aufgewachsen ist
genauso interessant sein
wie seine ethnischen Wurzeln.
Nach denen könnt ihr dann fragen,
was dann viel natürlicher wirkt:
Du hast asiatische Wurzeln, oder?
Macht euch bewusst,
dass die Frage nach der Herkunft
nicht unbedingt
eine leichte Small Talk Frage ist,
sondern auch mit viel emotionalem
Ballast belastet sein kann.
Wenn man das weißt, kann man
diese Frage sensibler stellen.
Darf ich dich etwas Persönliches
fragen? Was sind deine Wurzeln?
Und an die Gefragten:
Man kann ja respektvoll
darauf hinweisen,
dass Herkunft
etwas Vielschichtiges ist.
Was meinst du?
Wo ich herkomme oder meine Wurzeln?
Wenn einen die Frage nervt,
kann man das ja auch höflich sagen.
Ehrlich gesagt
nervt mich diese Frage ziemlich,
weil ich mich dadurch ausgegrenzt
fühle in meinem eigenen Heimatland.
Aber ich weiß,
dass du es nicht böse gemeint hast.
Wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, darüber
zu reden, ist das verständlich,
es ist ja auch anstrengend.
Ich will ja auch nicht immer
so eine Riesenkiste aufmachen,
wenn ich nur Small Talk
halten möchte.
Es ist euer gutes Recht,
diese Frage nicht zu beantworten,
aber es ist nicht euer Recht, euch
über die Unwissenheit aufzuregen.
Damit kommen wir zum letzten Punkt,
auf den wir uns einigen sollten:
Bei aller Anstrengung:
Wenn wir, die wir es persönlich
erleben, nicht aufklären, wer dann?
Falls das hier das erste Video
sein sollte, dass ihr mit mir seht:
maiLab ist normalerweise
ein Wissenschaftskanal,
aber weil es eben auch maiLab ist,
ist es halt mein Kanal.
Und als Deutsch-Vietnamesin
wollte ich das gerne loswerden.
Nächste Woche geht es
regulär weiter mit Science.
Wenn euch das interessiert,
könnt ihr gerne abonnieren.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin: bleibt sicher.